hey guys what is the 7th of October
today my name is Jess and you're tuned
in to games for news a number of
PlayStation 4 owners reported seeing
destiny pop up in their libraries which
would be a pretty normal thing except
that they hadn't purchased the game a
number of people were concerned their
accounts may have been compromised
but as is the way with a bunch of
ridiculous things that have happened
lately it's just marketing clicking on
the destiny of the taken King icon in
your game library will simply bring you
to the PlayStation Store and prompt you
to download the game or its demo
polygons have reported that this is
happening as a result of the PS wars
personalized and curated content feature
the ps4 website reads the ps4 system has
the ability to learn about your
preferences it will learn your likes and
dislikes allowing you to discover
content pre-loaded and ready to go on
your console in your favorite game
genres or by your favorite creators if
you'd like to unsubscribe from this
particular ability you can uncheck the
featured content box from the automatic
downloads menu within your system
settings in halo 5 things the game has
gone gold and we learned a bunch of new
things about it's for which mode
Microsoft has announced that the
development on the shooter is now
finished ahead of its October 27 release
producer Josh Holmes clarified that the
team is now working on a multiplayer
content update while an infographic has
revealed that Halo 5s 15 mission
campaign will take around 8 to 12 hours
Microsoft also published a meaty video
outlining the game's map editing Forge
tools orgy mode was originally
introduced in Halo 3 and although it
won't come to Halo 5 until December it's
looking to be worth the wait
in Halo 5 you can use voyage for any
area or break outs map but there are
also three large Maps designed to let
you flex your creative muscles properly
halo 5 sports mode includes and improved
controls
free camera precision editing over 1,600
objects many with object enhancement and
the ability to select and manipulate up
to 64 individual objects time for the
full list of changes and all the
nitty-gritty details that you can check
out our story on games but it's been a
little while since you've had about
cyberpunk 2077
but announced that afraid to read
they've come out to say the game will be
far far bigger than the witcher 3 visual
effects artists jose taste sierra told
MTV UK cyberpunk is far bigger than
anything else that said approached red
has done war he added The Witcher helped
cyberpunk quite a bit because the game
got so big and so complex that it really
taught us we really didn't know what was
going to happen if anything working on
The Witcher 3 was a really good and
often virtual learning experience
cyberpunk is going to benefit greatly
for it I can almost guarantee it let me
know down in that comment section if
you're keen for Halo 5 sports mode and
why or why not you can add your games
but we've got stories on a rise of the
Tomb Raider DLC path and
never-before-seen aren't four fortress
and de cancel Final Fantasy games that
is everything I have for you today as
always let me know what you cared about
and I will catch you tomorrow